the Macy's Thanksgiving Day Parade will
be in full swing this morning after it
was scaled back last year due to the
pandemic the New York City Police
Department is ramping up security to
protect Spectators and Marchers this
comes after six people were killed by a
driver who plowed through a Christmas
Day Parade in with our Christmas parade
in Wisconsin Elise Preston is along the
parade route in Manhattan Elise good
morning
good morning Dana now these festive
floats will take off in just a bit
they'll pass 360 thousand pounds of
concrete barriers along the way just one
of many steps being taken to ensure
safety
you guys are good close it up the
balloons are ready to take flight AS
Spectators flock back to the streets of
New York City to watch the 95th annual
Macy's Thanksgiving Day Parade and with
returning crowds will come increased
security this parade typically has two
to three million people that align the
47 block Parade route that's what makes
this such a giant security concern James
Galliano is a CBS News security and law
enforcement analyst what kind of
preparations go into making sure that
this stays safe for the families here
and for people watching at home so we
look at this from three perspectives
deterrence intelligence and response
among the deterrents will be officers on
rooftops and thousands patrolling on
foot including counterterrorism teams
you're going to see hundreds of cement
blocks sand trucks blocker Vehicles
you'll see our explosive detection
canines dozens of streets near the
parade have been closed and 300 extra
cameras deployed along the Route
law enforcement is on high alert after
an SUV drove through a crowd at a
Christmas parade in Waukesha Wisconsin
earlier this week but Galliano says he
suspects with so much security this
event will be one of the safest places
to be we're looking at the balloons
Isabel Kim and her mom Julie watched the
balloons get inflated Wednesday
afternoon that's her mom how does that
feel to be able to share this moment
with your daughter oh it's great it
feels a lot more like the holidays this
year
Julie told us she's always concerned
about safety at big events but they plan
to attend the parade anyway as a country
we need to come together and demonstrate
you know the holiday spirit and that
everybody can be together and be safe
[Music]
at New York City's Mayor Bill de Blasio
said yesterday there is no known
credible threat as for covid vaccination
requirements are not allowed along this
Parade route but the city is asking
everyone to wear a mask Michelle
they certainly are well Elise thank you
so much